at times Hollywood can seem like one
giant expensive recycling center with
rebirth sequels and remakes galore
pumping out of Tinseltown every other
week and while many of those projects
may be doomed from the start due to
audience disinterest bad timing or poor
production there are some remakes that
have proven to be worthwhile looking
ahead of what's coming up there are
quite a few in the works remakes that
might just work out well check these out
fire starter Stephen King readers and
pyromaniacs rejoice Akiva Goldsman
is set to direct a remake of firestarter
the 1984 film starring little drew
Barrymore which tells the story of a
young girl named Charlie who's
pyrokinetic and trying to escape the
clutches of an evil government entity
please don't make me do anything yes it
was totally a primer for Netflix
estranged of things which is probably
why it's the perfect time to revive this
explosive entry in the King Collection
Goldsman has some wide experience
dealing with drama and action
writing the scripts for a variety of
films like a beautiful mind I Robot and
The Dark Tower
so his screenplay skills will definitely
benefit the project as he's partnering
with Scott teams to car write the script
before taking the helm on the new
firestarter no word yet on who played
Charlie but the role will definitely
present some up-and-coming actress with
an incredible opportunity to showcase
her star potential and light the silver
screen on fire
Papillon as the undisputed king of cool
Steve McQueen is a mighty hard act to
follow but that's not going to stop
Charlie Hunnam from giving it a shot the
Sons of Anarchy actor is starring in a
remake of Papillon the 1973 film based
on the memoirs of an reach Aria a french
criminal convicted of murder
Sharia escaped from Devil's Island
before writing his best-selling book
I didn't kill that pump this time Panem
will sport the titular tattooed but
he'll need a little help escaping from
his South American prison in the
original film McQueen's character was
assisted by the counterfeiter Lewis
dagger played by Dustin Hoffman in the
remake
rami malek of mr. robot Fame will be
taking on the role and Michael Noah will
direct el descon Acedo
released in 2015 eldest conocido was a
spanish thriller that feels a whole lot
like the Keanu Reeves classic speed
Wow the movie follows a banker who's
driving his kids to the school one day
when he receives a phone call telling
him the car is rigged with a bomb
that'll detonate if he doesn't do as
he's told as to the remake well if
you're going to cast a guy who's trying
to protect his family from a terrorist
who would you pick
other than Liam Neeson one only the
action star will play a Wall Street
executive caught in the game of life or
death and instead of being titled eldest
conocido the movie will be known as
retribution disorder aka
Maryland have you ever wondered what
would happen if the director of Logan
teamed up with the screenwriter of hell
or high water well the answer is Magic
Grimm blood-splattered magic it's coming
soon to a theater near you
it's too big that's what she said James
man sculpt and screenwriter Taylor
Sheridan have teamed up to remake the
French thriller disorder also known as
Maryland a film about a retired Special
Ops soldier with PTSD who's hired to
protect the wife and kid of a big-deal
businessman the remake will be set in
Spain and a romantic subplot will give
the new protagonist a different
affliction the protagonist is also
described as a potential franchise
character which means he must get out of
the first film alive so a spoiler alert
as they say though it's not so much
about the destination as it is the
journey especially when it comes to
remakes like these miss Bala directed by
gerardo naranjo miss Bala impressed
quite a few critics when it debuted at
the Cannes Film Festival loosely based
on a true story this thriller follows a
Mexican beauty pageant contestant who's
kidnapped by a drug lord and forced into
becoming part of his gang and now the
spanish-language crime flick is about to
get an english-language adaptation Gina
Rodriguez of Jane the Virgin is set to
play the lead with Twilight director
Catherine Hardwicke at the helm but you
should probably expect fewer sparkly
vampires this turn around and much more
bloodshed
after all Bala is Spanish the bullet
Tony
Birdman in 2016 German audiences were
wowed by Tony Mann a comedy that many
considered one of the best movies of the
year the nearly three hour film follows
an elderly music teacher named Winfred
who tries to reunite with his business
minded got up by pretending to be Tony
admin a goofy life coach with a bad wig
and buck teeth in addition to winning
over film critics the movie also
impressed Jack Nicholson drawing the
Hollywood legend out of quasi retirement
after watching the film the actor went
to Paramount with the idea for a remake
and earned the lead in the pic with
Kristen Wiig playing the daughter
widow's one of the best filmmakers
working today Steve McQueen has directed
some truly incredible films like hunger
and 12 years of slave and now it looks
like the British director is getting
into the remake game only instead of
adapting a film he's going to give us
his own take on
a BBC TV series that first hit the
airwaves back in 1983 the original show
features a group of thieves that are
killed in a heist gone wrong so their
wives band together to finish the job
McQueen has had the project on his radar
since at least 2014 but now things are
really coming together
the director co-wrote the film with gone
girl author Gillian Flynn has since
assembled an impressive cast list that
includes Liam Neeson : Ferrell Michelle
Rodriguez
Viola Davis Robert Duvall Elizabeth
debicki Daniel Kahlua and Jacki Weaver
the film makes its way to dealers in
November 2018 train to Busan while it
slipped past most Americans train to
Busan was a major hit in South Korea the
horror film focuses on a work obsessed
dad who takes his unhappy daughter to
visit her mom but their trip is
interrupted by a swarm of attacking song
bees obviously as the danger escalates
the central hero arrives as someone
who's only looking out for himself and
his kid but aims to work with fellow
passengers to protect everyone onboard
critics fell in love with train to Busan
and so did audiences like the best
zombie movies the movie blends monsters
with metaphor and now it's getting an
english-language remake set in the US no
word yet on who direct or starring the
pic but if it's even half as exciting as
the original this one will be worth the
ride invasion of the Body Snatchers
based on Jack Finnish classic novel
invasion of the Body Snatchers has
inspired generations of movies there
were several different film adaptations
of the story before the concept of alien
body takeovers saw its way into other
films like Halloween 3 and the faculty
now it looks like the pod people like
gearing up for another attack Warner
Brothers is planning a new invasion of
the body snatchers remake with help of
producer John Davis with its eerie
aliens and infectious paranoia
filmmakers have consistently used the
creepy plot to address all sorts of
cultural fears from communist witch
hunts and 1970s cults to the military in
these contentious times it'll be
interesting to see what modern-day
topics screenwriter David Leslie Johnson
will tackle there aren't any updates yet
on who will star the rest assured coming
thanks for watching click the lubricants
and subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]